diese entdeckung könnte laut fachwelt
einen wissenschaftlichen wendepunkt
bedeuten und unser wissen über die neu
steinzeit drastisch verändern die
sprache ist von einer sensationellen
entdeckung in der nähe von jerusalem
hier hat alle archäologische ausgrabung
eine achtung 9000 jahre alte stadt
entdeckt eine steinzeit stadt total
verrückt und das wird die ganze
forschung in diesem bereich auf den kopf
stellen klicks uns ein fixie hier gibt
es täglich faszinierendes science videos
abonniert den kanal aktiviert die glocke
denn nur dann und nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
bei den ausgrabungen etwa fünf kilometer
vom heutigen jerusalem entfernt hat ein
israelisches archäologie team nicht nur
häuser struktur mit wohnräumen und
rituellen städten sondern auch
öffentliche gebäude von damals
aufgespürt dazwischen konnten auch
gassen freigelegt werden deren anordnung
unsere städten verblüffend ähnlich ist
auf eine ausgrabung fläche von mehr als
4000 quadratmetern konnten weitere
prähistorische wunsch stecken dünkel
sichergestellt werden beispielsweise
schmuckstücke und pfeilspitzen die wohl
von den ehemaligen bewohnern direkt vor
ort produziert worden waren aber nicht
nur das die forscher fanden auch
lagerschuppen in denen vor allem wo sie
vorräte an linsen entdeckt wurden nach
den analysen der fachleute handelt es
sich bei diesem fund um die überreste
einer ehemaligen siedlung die bis zu
3000 einwohner hatte für damalige
verhältnisse eine riesige metropole nach
ansicht des forschungsteams vergleichbar
mit dem heutigen jerusalem oder tel aviv
damit hat das forschungsteam absolut
nicht gerechnet für die damalige zeit
eine hightech metropole mit der dort so
niemand gerechnet hat existiert hat
diese siedlung wohl in der sogenannten
neu steinzeit genauer von 9000 jahren in
der fachsprache wird diese epoche auch
als neolithikum bezeichnet sie begann ab
ungefähr elf 1500 vor christus als sich
die jäger und sammler kulturen in mittel
und westeuropa zu sesshaften bauern
entwickelten die jetzt aufgespürte
siedlung ist die größte aus dieser zeit
die je
in israel aufgespürt werden konnte vor
allem die art der vorratshaltung
erstaunt den beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dazu der archäologe jacobi die tatsache
dass die samen konserviert wurden ist
angesichts des alters der städte
erstaunlich außerdem konnten zahlreiche
feuer steinwerkzeuge tausende von
pfeilspitzen messer und äxte freigelegt
werden
diese wurden wohl hauptsächlich für die
jagd und den kram sowie für das fällen
von bäumen genutzt die ausgrabung zeigen
also dass die menschen in dieser zeit
bereits intensive landwirtschaft
betrieben haben zudem gibt es auch
hinweise auf ausgeprägte tierhaltung und
das jagdverhalten der menschen damals so
wurden beispielsweise tierknochen
entdeckt die zeigen dass sich die sie
damals wohl zunehmend auf die haltung
von schafen spezialisiert hatten die
jagd auf tiere wurde somit stück für
stück weniger wichtig es konnten aber
auch noch weitere spannende artefakte
auf geschmückt werden unter anderem
muscheln aus dem roten meer und dem
mittelmeer diese zeigen dass die
bewohner der siedlung damals wohl
kontakt zu anderen bevölkerungsgruppen
hatten wahrscheinlich handelt es sich um
kulturelle und auch geschäftliche
beziehungen die auch über weitere
distanzen gepflegt worden waren zudem
konnte das forschungsteam auch einige
gräber aus spüren in einem grab wurden
zwei personen entdeckt die zusammen mit
einem speer und einem deutsch begraben
wurden die vorstand gehen deshalb davon
aus dass es sich um krieger gehandelt
hat zusätzlich zu den beiden waffen
hatten die damaligen siedler aber auch
noch einen esel in der nähe des grabes
vergraben die israelischen fachleute
gehen davon aus dass es sich auch bei
diesem tier um eine art grabbeigabe
handelt vermutlich gingen die bewohner
denn nun aufgespürten siedlungen davon
aus dass diese dem verstorbenen für ihre
reise in die nächste welt nützlich sein
könnten dass diese überraschenden kunde
überhaupt entdeckt worden sind das ist
ein großer zufall bis jetzt gingen
fachleute nämlich davon aus dass diese
region namens judäa in der neustadt zeit
unbewohnt waren erst der ausbau der
großen straße offenbarte was ich unter
der erde vermag dazu schreiben die
forscherinnen und forscher in einer
pressemitteilung an stelle eines
unbewohnten gebiet aus dieser zeit sind
wir auf eine komplexe städte gestoßen
und das alles nur einige dutzend
zentimeter unter der er
oberfläche die erkenntnisse die die
ausgrabungen ermöglichen sind aber nicht
nur für das beteiligte forschungsteam
ein großer erfolg dazu der archäologe
jakob war die die städte wird unser
wissen über die neu steinzeit drastisch
verändern
er bezeichnet es als urknall für die
erforschung von siedlungen und die
lebensweise ihrer bewohner in dieser
zeit er fasst es so zusammen tausenden
von jahren vor dem bau der pyramiden
passiert es in der jungsteinzeit dass
immer mehr bevölkerungsgruppen in einer
dauerhaften siedlung leben sie werden
sesshaft und beschäftigen sich mehr und
mehr mit der landwirtschaft warum
starben die neandertaler aus auch das
ist ein ungelöstes rätsel für das ein
französisches forschungsteam jetzt eine
neue erklärung hat anklicken anschauen
und klick substanzen fiktion abonnieren
die glocke nicht vergessen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran